FEMALE SPEAKER:
Well, thanks so much,
guys, for coming to the talk.
Really excited to have Rick
and Wendy Walleigh here
to talk about their book, "From
Silicon Valley to Swaziland,"
and to talk a little bit, also,
about the value and promise
of an encore career.
And then, also, we have Megan
Moyerman from TechnoServe
who will talk a little
more about the organization
and other ways to get involved.
Because encore careers
aren't the only ways to get
involved with TechnoServe--
though they are a great one.
So, Megan will kick it off.
MEGAN MOYERMAN: So
I just want to say
I'm really happy to be here.
So thanks for
having me, Lindsey,
and for having Rick
and Wendy here.
I think we're all excited.
So, as Lindsey
said, I'm just going
to talk a little bit about
TechnoServe, an introduction
to our organization.
We believe in the power
of private enterprise
to transform lives.
Just a quick look
at one crop, coffee.
Coffee is a really important
cash crop for more than nine
million smallholder farmers.
And small family-run farms
contribute to more than half
of the world's coffee supply.
Unfortunately, nearly
half of those families
are living on less
than $1 a day.
And that's 4.2 million
households and about 20 million
individuals.
So we have here, a picture
of Jackeline Mukandori,
and she's a member of the Mizero
Coffee Farmers Cooperative
in Rwanda.
She grows coffee in about
one to two hectares of land.
And, in 2010, she produced about
90 kilograms of coffee beans.
She has seven children, and
she does have additional income
besides coffee.
So TechnoServe, through agronomy
training that we provided,
she learned how to
apply fertilizer,
how to prune her
trees, manage pests,
and other critical
skills that are
necessary for her to improve
the quality and the quantity
of her coffee.
TechnoServe also helped
establish local wet mills
so that they run as
small businesses,
and they help to
ensure that the coffee
beans that come from
Jacqueline's coffee
are of high quality.
And TechnoServe also helped
to connect these wet mills
with new markets so that
Jacqueline and her coffee
receive the best price.
And you might already
know this, but some
of the coffee from Rwanda
and other of our locations
that we work in, made
their way to Pete's Coffee
and some other
different coffee chains.
So that is exciting.
OK, so our mission-- TechnoServe
works with enterprising people
in the developing world.
And we do that to build
competitive farms, businesses,
and industries.
What do these words mean to us?
Enterprising-- so the
people that we work with
are hardworking, and
they are aspirational.
They are agents of
change, and they are
leaders in their communities.
Work with-- so we work
with them, not for them.
And we help them to acquire
the skills that they need
to have successful businesses.
We connect them to opportunities
that they previously just
were out of reach for them.
Competitive-- we
help build businesses
that can achieve
success-- small scale
or large, short and long term
success in the marketplace.
We also help to-- these
types of businesses
are sustainable
sources of change,
so they're long-term
sources of change.
And we're hoping that
they stay like that
long after TechnoServe
is out of the picture.
Our founder Ed Bullard,
almost 50 years ago,
went to Ghana for about
a year and volunteered
with his family.
And from that
experience, he really
believed that
talent is universal,
but, unfortunately,
opportunity is not.
TechnoServe develops business
solutions to poverty.
We help connect people
to capital, to markets,
to suppliers, to information.
And we believe that we're
partners in this process.
And I think that was a
big key to Ed Bullard when
he started the organization.
We're a nonprofit.
We've been around for,
again, almost 50 years.
So we've been around
for a long time.
We have programs in about
29 different countries.
We have about, a little
more than 1,400 employees--
the majority of whom
actually work in the field.
Only about 60 to
80 of our employees
work in US-- so DC, New
York, Connecticut, and then
also in London.
And in 2014, our revenue
was about $80 million.
So we're not small, and we've
been around for a long time.
We do a lot of work.
So what do our programs do?
Well, some of our programs
help develop capacity.
And we try to help individuals
and communities acquire
new skills.
We help them to share knowledge,
to apply opportunities or apply
technology that will help them
grow their business and farms
and help them be successful.
And some of these programs
involve financial literacy,
financial management training,
youth training-- so youth
leadership training.
We have farmer organization
strengthening--
we work with that-- intensive
operational support, and so on.
Our programs help strengthen
market connections.
So we help coordinate
among industry players,
and we help them connect
emerging farms and businesses
to capital, to
information, to suppliers.
Some of our programs
that involve this area
would include business
planning, market linkages,
supplier linkages, financial
services, and capital raising.
So, also, some of
our programs involve
or help us to improve
the business environment.
And that's where we encourage
self-sustaining economic
activity by addressing policies,
information, and incentives
that help markets
function better.
So our programs
within that region
would involve industry
strategic planning,
developing local agricultural
service organizations, youth
and gender focus-- so making
sure a lot of our programs
focus on youth and also
include a lot of women in them.
So we also have environmental
sustainability and ICT
innovation or integration.
And if you're not familiar
with what ICT means,
it's information
communication technology.
So, for instance,
working with farmers
to use their mobile
phones for bank
accounts, tracking financial
information, and all of that.
In 2014, we reached more
than 333 farmers, businesses,
and employees.
And we helped add more than $61
million in revenue and wages.
And we helped mobilize
more than $23 million
in new finance that's
necessary to grow markets
and to be successful in your
business and your farms.
And so we're back to Jacqueline.
What did TechnoServe
do for Jacqueline?
Just as a reminder,
Jacqueline grows coffee.
She has seven children.
And she lived on about $1 a day.
Well, TechnoServe helped her
to improve her farming, helped
her to produce better coffee,
and to have a better business.
She is holding, right now,
health insurance cards
that she was able to purchase
from the profits of her coffee.
And these health
insurance cards--
so, this health
insurance-- helped
her to get treatment for her
son who contracted malaria.
In addition, she was able to
open up a savings account.
So she's able to start saving.
And she also used
some of her savings
to purchase a cow so that
her family could drink milk.
So what does TechnoServe do?
TechnoServe uses
business solutions
to help improve the lives
of people living in poverty
in developing worlds.
So I'm going to actually turn it
over to Rick and Wendy Walleigh
now, who are going to talk
about their experiences
as Volunteer Consultants working
with TechnoServe in the field
and about their book
on that experience.
RICK WALLEIGH: Great.
Thanks, Megan.
So what do you do after
a successful career
in Silicon Valley?
Obviously, move to Swaziland
and work with poor people
and work for a nonprofit.
That's the obvious thing
to most high-tech veterans,
but that is what Wendy
and I did a few years ago.
And we'd like to
try and convince
you to think about doing
something similar at some point
in your life-- whether
you're at our stage,
where we were getting close to
a traditional retirement age,
or whether you just want to
take your career in a more
socially beneficial direction.
In any case, neurologists
tell us that,
if we want to keep our
brains young and active,
that we should challenge them
with new and different things.
And I can tell you
that, by working
with poor people
in Africa, you will
be challenged and learn new
things that you can never
have imagined.
For example, did you
know that, in Swaziland,
the traditional bride price
that a new husband would
have to pay to his future
father-in-law was 17 cows?
I never knew that,
but I learned.
And I also learned that you
could negotiate a discount
if the bride was not a virgin.
So, if the bride had a child
already or was obviously
pregnant when she
got married, that
was pretty much assured that
you could get a discount.
Now, I should tell you that
I did not learn any of this
by personal experience,
even though polygamy is part
of traditional Swazi culture.
I wasn't willing to go that
far for a local experience,
and Wendy might
have had something
to say about it, as well.
But, from more of
a work perspective,
I think you probably know
that our background is
in the high-tech industry
here in Silicon Valley.
My education was in engineering
and business-- nothing
to do with agriculture.
But if you work with poor
people in the developing world,
you're going to have
to work somewhere
in the agricultural value chain.
75% of the world's poor
are smallholder farmers.
So you will have to work
with them at some point,
in some way, if you're
going to work with the poor.
And so, as I did
that, in working,
I ended up working in a number
of different agricultural value
chains.
The one that I found
most fascinating
was the pork industry.
And I love the terminology.
Did you know that when
little piglets are born
they're called suckers?
And then, six weeks later,
they become weaners.
That's W-E-A-N-E-R-S-- they
don't become the other kind
of hot dog wieners
till much later.
So as males grow, they become
porkers and then baconers.
The females become gilts,
which is analogous to a heifer,
and then they become
breeding sows.
And breeding sows have litters
of about 10 suckers every six
months for three years.
And then, they become tired
sows-- no wonder, right?
And when they become
tired sows, their litters
start to decrease in size.
And so, then they become
wieners-- the hot dog type--
because they get
sent to the butcher.
So how did we get to Africa?
Well, as Wendy and
I got into our 50s,
we started thinking about
wanting to do something
more directly socially
beneficial as the end
of our careers.
And Wendy took the first step.
And after thinking about
what she wanted to do,
she became the vice president
of marketing and development
for the local chapter
of Junior Achievement.
And she took a
salary cut of 50%,
but she got to work
in areas that she
was interested in--
entrepreneurship, education,
and youth, primarily
young women.
So she did that for
three years, and then
I decided, well,
it's my turn, too.
I want to do this, as well.
I didn't know what I
wanted to do, though.
So I started thinking about it.
And as I did, I realized I
could do anything I wanted to.
I didn't have to worry
about my next raise.
about a promotion.
I didn't have to worry
about my next job.
So I really expanded my mind
and thought about, well,
what would I like to do?
And so, to make a long story
short, I did a lot of research.
I read about 15 books on
international development.
I did a lot of
networking, and I found
TechnoServe, whose
tag line is "business
solutions to poverty."
And with my background
and Wendy's background,
as well, they had roles that
we could fulfill and support.
So I contacted the CEO, who
was Bruce McNamer at the time.
I met with him and
talked about TechnoServe.
And he introduced me to the
Volunteer Consultant Program.
For those of you who
haven't heard of it,
we call them volcons--
V-O-L-C-O-N-S--
Volunteer Consultants.
And so, I was ready to sign
up for a role right away.
WENDY WALLEIGH: I was not.
Rick and I, over the
years, had talked
about living abroad,
the international career
assignment.
Paris, London, Hong Kong
were what I imagined.
When we started talking
about international economic
development, I
kind of understood
those were out of the picture.
So I said, OK, I'm
willing to go along.
You need to do
really good research
and make sure we're able
to do this financially,
because I figured we were not
going to make money on this.
And I said, but I have
four absolute conditions
for any place we want to
go-- no flying bullets,
must have hot showers,
must have flush toilets,
and no countries with
"stan" in their names.
So that eliminated a few
countries, but not many,
and probably eliminated much
of the Peace Corps work.
But I figured, when
I was ready to leave,
I wanted to be in a place
where I could be generally
comfortable-- recognizing I was
going to move far, far away.
So it took me a while
to get ready to leave
Junior Achievement.
I had to finish a major project.
But when I was ready, Rick and
I had both sent our resumes
to the volcon
manager at the time,
and she sent them out
immediately to the country
directors across TechnoServe.
And within less
than 48 hours, we
got a contact from the
Swaziland country director,
who had opportunities
for both of us
with each of our
different skill sets.
And she said, can you
be here later this week?
We were not quite ready,
but, within a month,
we were living in Swaziland.
So when some people ask, how
did you choose Swaziland?
We say, it chose us.
So that's how we got there.
RICK WALLEIGH: So the journey
from San Francisco to Swaziland
is about as far as
you can go on earth.
It took us 36 hours--
two overnight legs,
four flights in
total-- and we finally
got to Matsapha
International Airport
near Manzini, Swaziland.
Now Matsapha
International Airport
is a very, very small airport.
Their whole boarding lounge
is less than half the size
of this room.
And so, however, it's
Swaziland's only airport,
so by definition it's an
international airport.
So we got there, and we were
hoping that our driver would
be outside and waiting for us.
Fortunately, he was, and
he had pictures of us
so that he could
recognize who we were
as we came out of the lounge.
But it wasn't a big problem,
since we were the only
white people on the plane.
So we were easy to recognize.
As got out of the airport,
we went into our office,
saw the office, and
started our work.
And I'll make it a
short part, go quickly
through our work experience.
We worked in Swaziland for
six months, and, after that,
we decided, well,
that wasn't bad.
We feel like we could
tolerate some more,
and we wanted to
contribute some more.
So we asked the regional
vice president for Africa,
and he said, oh, yeah.
Go up to Kenya for another
year and work up there.
So we did that.
So, in Swaziland, I worked
mostly with small businesses,
trying to help them create jobs,
create economic opportunity.
Wendy worked
primarily to start up
a youth program,
which turned out
to be Junior Achievement
of Swaziland.
We also worked on the business
plan competition in Swaziland.
In Kenya, I took on a
different kind of role.
I took on an internal role,
because the country directors
of Kenya and Uganda
were brand new.
They'd never been
country directors before.
They hadn't had those kind of
management responsibilities.
So I worked to support
them, primarily
on improving project
management and improving
internal financial management.
Wendy worked primarily,
again, on youth programs
with Young Women in Enterprise.
And then, once again, we both
worked on the business plan
competition.
So would you like
to show some slides?
WENDY WALLEIGH: Yes.
RICK WALLEIGH: OK.
WENDY WALLEIGH:
So I'll let you--
RICK WALLEIGH: I'll click.
WENDY WALLEIGH: Most of
these are-- well, first
of all, let's start with, for
those not familiar with where
the heck Swaziland
is-- as you can see,
it's surrounded on three sides
by South Africa and one side
by Mozambique.
It is landlocked.
It is a tiny country.
I think it's under the
size of New Jersey,
bigger than Rhode Island,
just to give you an idea.
And it's about a million
people, versus Kenya,
which has its own coastline
and has I don't know how many
millions of people.
40--
RICK WALLEIGH: 30, I think.
WENDY WALLEIGH: 30-40 million.
And the city of Nairobi
has about four million.
So we went from a city of
Mbabane, which is 100,000,
to a city of four million.
OK.
This, in my estimation,
is a tired sow.
She certainly looks
tired, and I'm not
sure you can count
every single piglet,
but I think it's a
slightly smaller litter.
So we're just going to
call her a tired sow.
Rick and I were able
to finish projects
while we were in our
six months in Swaziland.
I was very excited that
we were able to establish
Junior Achievement of Swaziland,
and we piloted our first class
before we left.
So Rick and I each taught part
of this class called, Personal
Economics.
And the goal of the class is
to teach kids about managing
their money, the
importance of staying
in school to get a career,
how you have to negotiate
in the world at large.
And one of the things that
we had a talk about was debt.
Now, thinking about it,
most of the curriculum
is based on Western knowledge
and it was a Western curriculum
that I adapted.
But it still was pretty
based in Western culture.
And one of the elements
was credit card debt.
And the kids said, that's
the most stupid thing
I've ever heard.
Why would you spend more
money than you have?
As Megan and Rick
referred to, Swaziland
helps-- or TechnoServe with
agricultural value chains.
Sometimes they help the
farmers, and sometimes they
help people like this, which is
Eswatini Kitchens in Swaziland.
And they process
fruits and vegetables
from the local
smallholder farmers.
So they take in stuff
that is grown locally
and to make sauces,
including ketchup, and fruits
and vegetable sauces.
And they cook it on
pretty primitive stoves--
kind of like a burner like this,
with the pot that's that big,
and that's how they do it.
And yet, they're able to
get fair trade certified
and are selling in Sweden,
and Germany, in South Africa,
and Swaziland.
So that is pretty impressive
for an operation that size.
So that was Eswatini Kitchens.
That's Rick.
And, yes, one of these
are what he was wearing.
So, Rick, our son Adrian who
came to visit us, and Mkhululi
was one of our colleagues
in the office, his daughter,
and his wife Katie.
And, particularly,
Mkhululi persuaded us
that he thought,
when we were going
to attend the national
major festival,
called the Annual
Reed Dance, that we
needed to go in costume.
And so, the nature of
the Annual Reed Dance
is that the traditional
homes are made out
of reeds, kind of like a
shaped dome made out of reeds.
And the theory is that,
every year, the queen mother
needs to have her
reed home repaired.
So all the young women
across the entire country
gather reeds and bring
them to this one location
to help the queen
mother rebuild her home.
That's part one
of the operation.
Part two is that then these
young women sing and parade
in front of the
king in the hopes
that they will be his next wife.
So Mswati-- it's Mswati,
right-- the Third, I think.
But he was the king at the time.
He was already on
wife number 14.
So, I think now
he has number 15.
His father had 83 wives.
We were not going to go there.
But in any case, so
there we were in costume,
and we entered this very
large football-like stadium.
And we were certainly only a
handful-- among only a handful
of white people.
And we had to walk across
the whole end of the stadium
to get where we could sit.
I think we had as much attention
on us as the young women.
Well, the other thing about
the young women that was unique
is that they were topless.
About a decade ago,
they were naked.
But they had a little PC and
were able to just be topless.
So, obviously, Rick and
Adrian, our son, enjoyed that.
But even they said, after the
first 10,000 pairs of boobs,
they kind of all look alike.
So we left.
One of the programs that I
worked on when we were in Kenya
was called Upscaling.
And this program helped
small, micro businesses
grow to expand the
number of employees
that they would be able to hire.
And this was Aspen Orchards.
They created yogurt drinks.
And it started pretty
small, out of his own home--
the gentleman who ran it-- and
cooked pretty much like you
saw in the Eswatini Kitchens--
a single, big burner
stove with a big pot.
And he was very
successful in his area
and was bottling yogurt
drinks and selling them
to the local markets.
And they were very popular.
So he had an internal
process for getting
the bottles ready for market.
You can see the labels.
And every bottle
was hand-labeled.
was hand-sealed.
So the little foil tops that
you see in a lot of things,
they use an iron to
iron those on by hand.
So the good news is
they were able to hire
a number of local youth
to actually do this.
So he was a very
successful small business.
We helped him with his
finance and accounting
so that he would be able
to grow his business.
I was also involved with
Young Women in Enterprise,
as Rick mentioned.
This is the Mathare,
which is one
of the major slums in Nairobi.
This is a typical back
street, if you will,
or back alley behind the
homes that look like that.
They are powered
by propane lights,
and you have to walk, even
in here, to get your water.
So it's pretty
primitive, but it's
right on the edge of Nairobi.
The program, Young
Women in Enterprise,
gathers young women from
different circumstances,
often in communities like
this, and teaches them
how to behave in business,
how to run a business,
and it also teaches
life skills--
so some commonality with Junior
Achievement, plus the life
skills.
And it was totally
funded by Nike.
And that's a Nike representative
in the back who came to visit.
So we took him on
a tour of Mathare.
And that's Esta Proshoto--
not Esta Proshoto,
that's another person.
RICK WALLEIGH: Kamau.
WENDY WALLEIGH:
Kamau-- Esta Kamau.
Who was one of our
colleagues on the program.
So we were giving him
a tour of the area.
This is one of the businesses.
And this young woman,
who's kind of bending over
in the back, her business
was selling hot boiled milk
to local people in
her Mathare area.
And, again, she used a
pretty primitive stove
and a pretty primitive
pot, and took milk in,
boiled it so it was
clean, and sold it
to people and to
little kids, and was
able to make money at it.
The young women that
were helped were often
what they called school
leavers, which we call dropouts.
So giving them the tools to
be able to have a business
or be employed
successfully in a business
was really important to them.
And being able to handle
their various relatives, who
might want to take
advantage of them,
was also a big element
of what we were doing.
This young woman is
Cecilia Katungwa.
She was the winner of
the regional competition.
So, once the young women went
through their class exercises,
they will then be able to
create a three-page business
plan, which they then had
to present to local judges
from the business community.
And the winners of those
club contests, or community
contests, were then went to the
regional contest in Nairobi.
And Cecilia was
the winner of that.
She had started a
knitting business, where
she took a little
knitting machine-- a hand
one, not anything
that was electrified,
a hand knitting machine--
and created clothing
for babies, sweaters, vests,
scarves, et cetera, for adults.
And she was
extremely articulate.
I don't know if you can see
it, but it's like 30,000--
what looks like $30,000
but it's Kenya shillings,
which amounts to
maybe $300-$400,
depending on the exchange.
But that was her grand prize.
Amazing young woman.
We talked about the
value chain that's
typical in what a project
of TechnoServe's is.
This was matoke
farmers in Uganda.
We went to visit them with some
other people from TechnoServe.
And the matoke banana
is a starch banana,
different from
what we have, which
is considered a dessert banana.
But what they do
is the matoke are
cooked while the fruit
is green and then mashed
as if it were mashed potatoes.
And it's a staple
in the Ugandan diet.
So, every week, as part of
the training, the young--
the farmers who became
part of the training
would go to a marketplace and
carry their 50 to 100 pound
bunches of bananas on whatever
mechanism they could do it.
Sometimes it was pull
carts that they pulled.
Sometimes it was donkeys.
And sometimes it was bicycles.
But they knew that every
week, at a certain time,
they would get their
matoke to market
and know that they
would get money,
which is a major
improvement over what
they had been able to do.
And here's a woman
who was receiving
some training on
fertilizer and irrigation,
as part of the matoke project.
And this is a
farming couple, also
part of the matoke project.
They had noticed
that beans, which
are an incredibly
important staple in Uganda,
the beans got low prices
during the harvest, when
they were plentiful, but
could be charged higher prices
during those off times.
And so they borrowed
money, got money
from their relatives
and friends,
and used some of
their own money,
and began storing dried
beans for those times when
they could make more money.
So, in essence,
unbeknownst to them,
they independently created
leveraged commodity buying.
This is a group that we talked
with when we were there--
one of the groups of
farmers who wanted to meet
was with us when
we were visiting.
And they had the desire
to ask questions and get
as much information from
us as we could provide.
And they also requested that we
help them open up the US matoke
market.
Unfortunately, we had
to tell them there
was no matoke market in the US.
They were disappointed,
but they were obviously
trying to be very enterprising
in their perspective of life.
And they asked me
to take a picture
with the women in the group.
They were delightful people.
And this was my new friend.
Along with beans,
most farmers had
secondary income from their
livestock-- goats, cows,
chickens, et cetera.
Rick would not let me
take him home with us,
but he was my friend.
This is a mall that was about
a quarter to a half a mile
from where we lived in Nairobi.
It was called Westgate Mall.
I don't know if you are
familiar with that name.
That was the mall
that was blown up
by Al-Shabaab a
couple of years ago.
67 people died.
100 and some odd 50,
60 people were severely
injured by four men who
came in and just took over.
This is the mall that was
where we went to most weekends.
It's where we shopped for food.
It's where we ate.
It was walking distance
from our apartment,
and we went there every weekend.
So it was horribly upsetting
to hear about that.
The good news was it just
reopened this past summer.
So it's back to, hopefully,
looking something like that.
RICK WALLEIGH: One of
our main objectives
in writing this book
was, as I said before,
to encourage other
people-- whether you're
our age or your age-- to go
out and experiment and try
something like this and find
your own next chapter that
can have both purpose
and adventure.
And in the book, we give
a number of suggestions
on thinking about this
and what you should do.
And I'll just give
you a couple today.
The first one is do
something that excites you.
Particularly if you're our
age and you're doing this
as the last stage
in your career,
all the restrictions are off.
You don't have to do
what you've always done.
You can think about new things.
And, if you've always had an
idea in the back of your head
that you wanted to do something
or experiment with something,
that's the time to do it.
You can also do this at a
break in your career, as well.
And it's a great
opportunity to have a chance
to explore something
new and different
and help people
at the same time.
The other suggestion
I would have
is to do something that makes
you feel good about yourself.
Particularly as you get
later in your career,
people start to think
about their legacy,
and they think about asking
questions, such as am I
proud of my life, am I
proud of what I've done,
am I happy if I look back on my
life at what I've accomplished.
And when they do
that, people start
to think about giving back,
particularly if they've
been fortunate in their lives.
And that's a real opportunity
to do something good
for the world, but
also psychologists
tell us that people that
do things for other people
feel happier themselves.
And so, I would urge
you to think about that,
to do those kinds of things.
And what's important is not
what other people think,
but what you think
about yourself.
Now, on the other
hand, I can tell you
that it does feel good when
somebody else recognizes
what you have done
and compliments you.
I had an experience
that way in Swaziland.
I mentioned the business
plan competition,
where we not only took
in the business plans,
but we trained people
in business concepts
along the way.
And, one day, I was at
the Swazi Sun Hotel,
and a young man walked up to me.
He introduced himself.
His name was Thembisa.
I didn't recognize him
at first, but he knew me.
And he said that I had
done some of the training
that he had attended.
And he'd been a participant in
the business plan competition.
He had had the idea to start
up a mobile hair salon,
where he would
take his equipment,
go to people's houses--
particularly in off hours--
and then cut and
color their hair.
And he'd been thinking about
doing that for a long time,
but he hadn't had the
confidence to actually start up
the business.
He felt like he knew about
some parts of the business
but not the other parts.
And so that had held him back.
But, with the training
that TechnoServe gave,
he had confidence that he was
going to go out and start up
his business.
And so, he was very thankful
that we had come to TechnoServe
and had come to Swaziland
and that TechnoServe
had put on this business
plan competition.
And he had been a semifinalist.
He didn't make it
into the finals,
but we were doing some more
work with the semifinalists
to keep them going.
And he said he really thanked
God for sending TechnoServe
to Swaziland and us included.
So I felt rewarded
much more than I
deserved with that experience.
So, in conclusion, just do it.
Go out there, be
adventurous, have fun,
do something good for the
world, and feel good about it
yourself.
So thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: The role
of technology-- so,
you know, you're going in,
you're working with farmers,
things like.
How do you see--
and I actually don't
know when you were
in Swaziland--
but how do you see technology?
Especially, working at
Google, can our products
even help solve any
of these problems
that you're dealing with
in these small areas?
I'm just curious, because
I think, as a lot of Google
is focusing on emerging
markets and places in Africa,
where they have mobile phones,
they're growing very rapidly,
and we want to figure
out how can we help
in these kind of situations?
I'd love to hear your
thoughts on that.
RICK WALLEIGH: Yeah.
Absolutely there's
opportunities for technology.
We already are doing a number
of things with technology.
And, as smart
phones get cheaper,
there will be a lot
more opportunities.
Some of the things
that are available now
in some countries, I
think you've probably
heard of M-Pesa in Kenya.
If you haven't heard about
it, this is basically
banking on your phone.
So, without a bank
account in a bank,
it's just through the phone,
through the phone company,
you can send and receive money.
You can have a balance,
and it's very simple.
They're way ahead of
us in that regard.
There's a lot of communication
that happens with farmers,
both directions-- telling
farmers what the prices are
in various markets
for their produce
so that they can choose to go
to this town, or this town,
or that town to
sell their produce.
There are advisories coming
out that say, OK, now
is the time to apply
fertilizer, or think
about pruning your trees.
There's a lot of work going
on today-- a lot of concern
about traceability of food
through the value chain.
Particularly if
there's a problem,
people want to
search back and say,
where did that problem come from
so that we can eliminate it.
But a lot of concern--
a lot of requirements,
particularly to get into the
EU for the traceability of
produce.
And so technology offers a lot
of opportunity there with GPS
tracking and being able to link
the location of the farm that
produced some produce
and tracking that
through the value chain.
So some other
examples-- we've set up
a portal that is a coffee
transparency portal,
where, for each co-op,
we show the price
that the co-op
paid to the farmer
for their coffee and the price
that they got in the market.
And so, this is a way to
make everything visible.
Because there's a
lot of corruption,
as you probably know.
And sometimes the people that
run the co-ops skim a little
off the top as it goes through.
And so, if you see that
your co-op is giving you
a lot lower price
than everybody else,
you start to ask questions.
And so, there's a few examples.
But there are lots more
opportunities, and, as I say,
regular, traditional cell
phones are really cheap,
and they're pervasive, and
text messaging is really cheap.
With smart phones, there's
lots of opportunities,
and hopefully they'll
come down in price.
And there will be more
and more things to do.
WENDY WALLEIGH: But
still, the internet
is not the dominant
means of communication.
RICK WALLEIGH: Yeah.
WENDY WALLEIGH: There's
no infrastructure in place
to do that.
So I think phones will probably
be the dominant communication
tool for quite a while longer.
RICK WALLEIGH: Yeah, yeah.
AUDIENCE: So one of
the biggest problems
I faced, when I
was in Panama, when
trying to use business for
sustainable development,
was trying to change the
villagers mindsets of,
kind of like what you mentioned
with the credit card of they
couldn't even conceive of the
fact of spending more money
than they had.
Well, when I tried to explain
the fact of making a profit,
they didn't really understand
why would they sell something
to someone who needed
it for more money
than maybe that
person had to offer.
And it was very nice to see
that, from my point of view,
in this selflessness
that we don't really
see too often here in kind
of a competitive culture.
But, in the sense that business
development, to be sustainable,
of course, you need to make
money to have these savings,
and I'm just curious if
in Swaziland you kind of
met some resistance to that
kind of just a cultural mindset,
or--?
RICK WALLEIGH: We
didn't see exactly that,
but what we've seen in
a number of countries
is also a cultural mindset
of how can I be successful?
We've done a number of
programs with youth,
who just see things
the way they are,
see what their
parents did, and they
don't have an idea that they
can actually have a business
and make money.
Particularly in farming-- as I
said, 75% of the world's poor
are smallholder farmers, and
it's primarily subsistence.
They don't think about, well,
gee if you have extra milk,
you could sell it.
Or, if you have a
couple of chickens,
you could sell the eggs.
Or, you could have
subsistence crops over here
to feed your family, and you
can have a cash crop over here
and make a cash income.
And so, a lot of the training
that we've done with youth
has been to open up their
eyes about opportunities
and to give them the confidence
that they can do it themselves.
So, different cultural
issues, but cultural issues--
analogous cultural issues.
WENDY WALLEIGH: I think
the other thing is it often
takes a leader who is going
to take a risk to kind of be
at the forefront of
whatever recruitment
you're trying to put in place.
And so, TechnoServe often
looks for the local leaders
in an area and pull
them in, and then
people go, well, if he's doing
it, maybe I should do that.
So it's kind of almost like
a standard business practice
where you look for people
who are risk takers,
and you try to bring
them to what you want
them to start being able to do.
And then, it kind of
ripples out from there.
AUDIENCE: So I'm a
little bit curious
about how, specifically, your--
you said you had an engineering
and sales background--
how that sort of allowed
you, what skills you were
able to gain there, how that
specifically allowed you
to help in Swaziland--
sort of the application of that.
RICK WALLEIGH: OK.
Well, it didn't teach
me to be a pig farmer,
but TechnoServe's approach is
business solutions to poverty.
So we believe in building
up the private sector,
independent businesses, to
get people out of poverty.
And so, in Swaziland,
I was primarily
working with small businesses.
Now, I couldn't
advise the pig farmers
on how to feed the pigs
better, or take care of them
better, whatever-- but I could
teach them about finances
and get them to look
at their business
and whether they were
making money or not.
I worked with
another company that
was trying to pressure-treat
poles for telephone poles,
and I put together a
business plan for them,
so that they could get
financing to build the factory
to do the pressure
treating, et cetera.
So that's the kind of thing.
I used my business skills.
I didn't have to learn baking,
or water treatment, or raising
pigs, or what have you.
So yeah.
We've given this talk,
or similar talks,
at a number of different venues.
And a month or so ago, we
were at the Los Altos Library,
and, at the end of the talk,
the woman in the back row
raised her hand
and said, well, I
came tonight, because I had been
in Swaziland after you left.
And I lived there a couple
of years with my husband.
And she said the
strangest thing-- Thembisa
used to cut my hair.
He would come to my
house and cut my hair.
And he did a great job.
And so, I was really
pleased to hear about that.
So that was a great experience.
One more thing-- after
the presentation,
feel free to take a book.
They've got donation envelopes
in there for TechnoServe.
So hopefully you will give
TechnoServe a donation,
but feel free to take one.
MEGAN MOYERMAN: I'm just going
to talk about ways that you
can get involved, as
well, with TechnoServe
if you're interested.
The first way is very
similar, or the same as what
Rick and Wendy did, is through
the Volunteer Consultant
Program.
I'm actually the
manager of that program.
And then also through the
Global Advisory Council.
And Lindsey knows a lot
about that, as well.
Volunteer Consultant Program--
again, Rick and Wendy Walleigh
did this.
We have been around
since about 2001.
We've engaged more than
970 Volunteer Consultants.
We've sent them
out into the field.
They work with our
full-time staff
to further the mission
of TechnoServe.
We send them to places
in Africa, in India,
and also Latin America,
and the Caribbean.
And they could go for about,
anywhere from two to three
months to 12 months.
Sometimes people will
do two-year projects.
So they'll do one year, and then
they'll do a whole other year.
But that's a little less common.
So if you're interested
in that or you
want to learn a little
bit more about it,
feel free to talk to me.
Also our site is there.
So technoserve.org/volunteer,
so you can read more there,
and the applications is there.
The other option is through
the Global Advisory Council.
And we call them GAC members.
So GAC members, they're
ambassadors for TechnoServe.
So they help with
financial support,
but they also help
with strategic advice.
They give strategic
advice, and they also
help connect TechnoServe
with other people
and other organizations,
and hopefully
help with increasing the
support for TechnoServe, too.
So there are some really
interesting things
that I think you can
get involved with.
If you did decide to
be part of the GAC,
there's an annual meeting that
happens in December every year.
And I think, Rick, you spoke
to the last one, right?
RICK WALLEIGH: Yes.
MEGAN MOYERMAN: So
that was interesting.
There is also council meetings.
There are reports that you get
to receive about TechnoServe
that other people outside
don't actually get to see.
And then, there's
actually field visits.
So, for instance, I
think Peru was one.
AUDIENCE: Ethiopia.
MEGAN MOYERMAN:
Ethiopia is another.
So you get to see what
TechnoServe projects do
and meet some of the
beneficiaries, too.
I think that's a really
interesting part.
There are some requests
for being a GAC member.
There is a annual
gift of $2,500,
and then, also, to help
further TechnoServe's name,
get the name out
there, and to help
connect us to other
supporters, as well.
So those are a
couple ways you can
get involved with
TechnoServe, and feel
free to talk to us about
it if you're interested.
But, otherwise,
that's where we are.
We're located in DC.
That's actually where I am, too,
and I think that's pretty much
it.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Well, a
huge thank you, again,
to Rick and Wendy and to
Megan, for coming today.
And thanks to everyone
here for joining,
and I guess thank you to the
people that will watch this
in the future online, as well.
So thanks.
[APPLAUSE]